confrontation point de vue ce soir entre
eric delannoy et eric heyer on va
revenir à froid sur ce qu'a proposé le
gouvernement lundi dernier pour les
salariés 10 de la deuxième ligne les
petits salaires
particulièrement exposée à la pandémie
les entreprises pour leur verser une
prime de 1000 euros en 2021
mais j'ai bien dit pourront parce que ce
n'est pas une prime obligatoire ce qui
rassure le medef ce qui inquiète les
syndicats vous l'imaginez bien avant
d'en parler avec nos invités les faits
et les réactions c'est avec aurélie en
mano la deuxième ligne ce sont les
éboueurs les caissiers ou encore les
livreurs pour eux la prime macron pourra
monter à 2000 euros
cette prime défiscalisées et exonérées
de cotisations sociales s'élève déjà à
1000 euros pour les bas salaires les
travailleurs de la deuxième ligne
devront bien entendu en être les
bénéficiaires privilégiées il s'agit de
manifester une reconnaissance aux
salariés dans la présence au travail
s'est avérée indispensable pour assurer
la continuité économique du pays tout au
long de la crise mais l'état n'est qu'un
site at her dans cette affaire le
versement de la prime sera au bon
vouloir des entreprises pour le medef
beaucoup d'entre elles sont déjà en
grande difficulté donc aucun engagement
n'est pris si vous voulez c'est l'année
où le sujet c'est comment on va pouvoir
maintenir des augmentations de salaires
ou des primes alors que la plupart d'un
prix encore une fois il ya des
exceptions seront dans une nation
financière difficile
et j'ajoute pardon peut dire que je vais
finir cette prime je ne sais pas vous
dire et je peux pas répondre pour toutes
les entreprises les syndicats craignent
que les entreprises ne jouent pas le jeu
il aurait souhaité un dispositif plus
contraignant afin de garantir le
versement effectif de cette prime à ceux
qui en ont réellement besoin
nous avons souhaité qu'ils aient un
droit de retour du gouverneur de l'état
si jamais les branches ne s'y engageait
pas c'est je pense que sur un certain
nombre de sujets il faut que l'état soit
plus intervenants rad c'est à dire quoi
des sanctions
oui ça veut dire qu'en tout cas il ya
une contrainte beaucoup plus forte du
goût de l'état sur ses branches
professionnelles sap a été retenue l'an
dernier la prime macron avait bien été
versée à 5 millions de personnes mais
qui avait touché en moyenne
458 euros donc assez loin du plafond de
1000 euros pour le match des idées ce
soir eric delannoy bienvenue vous êtes
économiste et président du cabinet
tenzing conseil eric heyer bienvenue
économistes également directeur du
département analyse et prévision de
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques eric heyer une prime non
obligatoire c'est comme s'il n'y avait
pas de primes non non surtout ici vous
l'incité un peu si vous la désocialisés
c'est à dire que si vous ne payez pas d
un certain nombre de cotisations ou si
vous la défiscaliser ça peut être un peu
incitatif
donc on a envie de dire c'est mieux que
rien une prime et oui il faut quand même
se souvenir quand même 2 pourquoi on la
met en place c'est pas uniquement pour
maintenir un pouvoir d'achat et c'est
ainsi qu'on s'est bien rendu compte
pendant cette crise tout de même qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de métiers qui
n'était pas ma paye alors juste valeur
c'était pas notion de productivité qu'il
fallait avoir mais une notion d'utilité
sociale et qu'il y avait certains
métiers qui étaient extrêmement utile à
la société et qui était extrêmement mal
rémunérés et donc il fallait revaloriser
ce type de métier là alors est ce qu'on
ne fait pas le prime
vous voyez bien une prime le problème
c'est que c'est que ponctuelle ça sera
pas donné à tout le monde
et voyez si vous êtes une entreprise qui
se porte bien elle peut elle peut donner
cette prime si vous êtes dans une
entreprise qui se porte pas bien
alors à part alors que vous faites
potentiellement le même métier oui bon
je dis pas qu'il faut pas le faire je
sais c'est pas simple comme comme façon
de faire mais je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir tout même à comment on
valorise ce type de métier parce que
effectivement peut-être qu'on aura
plusieurs pandémie et que ces métiers là
seront toujours en première ou deuxième
ligne
eh bien il va bien falloir qu'à un
moment on incite les grilles salariales
à prendre en compte cette utilité et
primes voyez ça n'ouvre pas des droits
forcément dans tout notre modèle social
donc il va falloir quand même qu'on
réfléchisse à cela la prime c c'est
quelque chose qui est insuffisant de
soins si c'est pas une remise à plat des
échelles de valeur c'est intéressant
vous disiez ça parce que en entendant
parler tu es tu prêt moi ça m'a rappelé
un entretien que j'avais eue avec
dominique méda sociologue et qui avait
eu ce genre de réflexion et qui nous
avait dit on peut organiser un
resserrement des salaires c'est à dire
une forme de vase communiquant avec les
rémunérations exorbitantes de certaines
professions qui se sont révélées
particulièrement invisible
utile pendant cette crise on peut aussi
utiliser l'instrument fiscal
c'est-à-dire augmenter à la fois l'impôt
sur le patrimoine sur la fortune et
créer de nouvelle tranche d'impôts sur
le revenu pour organiser la rémunération
d'un service rendu très important on est
là dans sur la question de l'échelle des
valeurs qu'ont pensé vous eric delannoy
je reconnais bien dominique méda quand
même en étant orientée essentiellement
effectivement sur l'échiquier politique
est néanmoins il ya sur le fond il ya
une vraie un vrai sujet de
revalorisation d'un certain type de
métier le problème c'est que l'utilité
économique et justice sociale
aujourd'hui ne coïncident pas
aujourd'hui pour une entreprise un
marketeurs de coca cola apporte plus de
valeur à l'entreprise coca cola qu'un
travailleur social
c'est dommage mais c'est malheureusement
comme ça mais est-ce qu'on va le voir et
donc c'est tout une architecture
économique il faudrait revoir et ça
c'est très compliqué les voeux pieux qui
consiste à de manière autoritaire
resserrer les salaires on essaie de le
faire dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire puisque je vous rappelle qu'il
ya des statuts qui existe qui exigent
pour obtenir ce statut là d'avoir un
resserrement du justement des salaires
de 1 20 on estime aujourd'hui que c'est
un peu la norme acceptable
il faut savoir que allait peu à la
grande époque
ford qui était incarné un des grands
capitalistes disait que quand on
dépassera les rapports de salaire de 1 à
100 on obtiendra des émeutes sociales
parce que ça ne sera pas socialement
aujourd'hui certaines entreprises comme
google on est de 1 à 1000 donc
donc c'est vrai qu'on peut sauf que le
faire de manière autoritaire ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens il faut faire par la
responsabilité aujourd'hui la loi pas
que va dans ce sens là ces a mené par la
responsabilité à prendre conscience que
les entreprises ont un enjeu social
modifier un travail de fond comme et un
travail de fond qui a commencé qui n'est
pas suffisant mais aller plus vite c'est
risquer de casser la machine
un exemple très concret pour reprendre
cette prime macron cette prime macron
allait bien sur le fond mais j'ai peur
que si on en fait quelque chose pour
reconnaître une deuxième ligne d'abord
on exclut un ensemble de professions qui
bat le deuxième ligne pas essentiel on
va vite tourner vers des sujets un peu
compliqué de se dire ce qu'il ya des
métiers utiles ou inutiles
je ne suis pas d'accord pour aller dans
ce sens là à titre personnel
deuxièmement la prime macron c'est peut
être aussi le moyen de bloquer
l'ouverture sur leurs réalisations
salariale parce que
de gens en termes notamment le patronat
en termes d'opportunités vont se dire
c'est à ma main je peux la payer ou ne
pas la payer c'est effectivement
extrêmement flexible donc pourquoi
j'irais vers une revalorisation plus
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre par
branche et donc mine de rien il peut y
avoir des effets contre-productifs très
important à faire en sorte de la mettre
en étendard plutôt que de se dire c'est
effectivement revalorisons pour les
entreprises qui le peuvent parce que là
monsieur roux de bézieux à la fois
raison est pas raison et la raison sur
le fait que tous les entreprises
pourront pas le faire mais néanmoins ce
qui était en deuxième ligne son
appartiennent toutes quasiment des
entreprises qui ne font pas partie des
zones des secteurs sinistrés
c'est aujourd'hui à la grande
distribution et des filles mais oui et
ils vont faire beaucoup beaucoup de
bénéfices etc eh oui mais il va falloir
que je suis assez d'accord
globalement ces entreprises là ont les
moyens de le faire ont touché comme un
certain nombre d' aide même dans un
premier temps quand même les aides ont
été général et pas à cibler sur sept qui
se portait pas bien donc lui-même ces
types d'entreprises ont pu avoir des
aides et donc c'est peut-être un juste
retour des choses
moi je pense que tout de même il va
falloir qu'on aille un peu plus loin
dans la présence des salariés dans les
conseils d'administration pour justement
éviter ces dérives
effectivement je suis d'accord avec vous
on est à l'aise de dd à des à des écarts
de salaires exorbitants et pourtant la
tension sociale n'est pas là ou pas plus
que parce qu'on n'est pas au courant
tout simplement personne ne sait
exactement combien est payé et voyez
parce que quand il ya des enquêtes
aujourd'hui sur qu'est ce que vous
pensez être raisonnable ça va 2 à 25 et
à 30 jamais d'un ami donc les gens ne
savent pas que ça va de 1 1 me et donc
du coup il faudrait un peu plus de
transparence sur les rémunérations aussi
ça veut dire que les salariés doivent
être à l'intérieur de ces conseils
d'administration pas forcément pour
prendre les décisions
mais pour observer ce qui s'y passe et
pour pourquoi pas un peu pesé dans dans
ces décisions là donc je pense que c'est
il ya tout une réforme avoir encore une
fois la prime
je vois bien on peut pas augmenter le
smic voyez donc effectivement c'est un
peu compliqué enfin d'augmenter le smic
au jour une autre consolation quoi et
donc c'est un lot de consolation mais
qui va pas jusqu'au bout d'histoire
effectivement on préférerait qu'ils
aient une augmentation du smic pas de
façon
autoritaire mais bien négocié et que les
salaires du bas soit un peu plus
revalorisé mais là vous voyez qu'on est
en train de juste d'inciter les chefs
d'entreprise pour aller beaucoup plus
loin de tout ça avance un peu quand même
parce que quand vous prenez le comité a
fait mais des fins qui est en fait ce
comité d'éthique qui n'a pas valeur de
loi
mais qui est une recommandation pour les
patrons dans notre organisation de
gestion et quand on voit les le travail
qui est fait sur la gouvernance esg
environnemental social gouvernance au
niveau européen on prend déjà en compte
ces aspects là c'est d'ailleurs par là
c'est que il existe dans les grandes
entreprises des comités de rémunération
maintenant il ya une obligation a publié
les salaires des délais plus des dix
plus gros salaires de l'entreprise
donc ça commence à venir quand même
maintenant effectivement le sujet
important c'est comment petit à petit on
fait coïncider l'utilité économique et
l'utilité sociale et ça c'est un
chantier qui est un chance et sociétal
gigantesque les jeunes souffrent aussi
financièrement de cette crise on en a
beaucoup parlé on a tous été frappés par
ces images de files d'attentes devant
les banques alimentaires et si on
mettait en place pour eux des tickets
resto ce n'est pas mon idée c'est l'idée
du sénateur centriste pierre antoine
lévy qu'on accueille tout de suite dans
ce match des idées bienvenue et merci
d'accepter de participer ponctuellement
à ce match des idées est-ce que vous
pouvez d'abord nous en dire plus
peut-être sur cette proposition de loi
que vous avez déposé cette proposition
de loi est également déposée par un don
blake et député de maine-et-loire
qu'elle a déposé cette loi à l'assemblée
nationale
le mois dernier nous sommes rendra
relation tous les deux j'ai également
auditionné les représentants du syndicat
étudiant uni qui qui a eu cette idée de
mettre en place un ticket restaurant
étudiants de plusieurs plusieurs années
donc j'ai des idées j'ai déposé cette
loi au sénat
donc cette fois été déposée la semaine
dernière elle a été cosigné par 79
sénateurs de quatre groupes politiques
différents ce qui montre bien que sur ce
sujet là tout le monde est capable de se
retrouver concrètement c'est quoi c'est
un ticket restaurant qui seraient
achetées par l'étudiant auprès du crous
et l'état abonderait de la même somme 3
euros 30 chacun sait ça aujourd'hui un
ticket restaurant d'une valeur faciale
de cidre 60 serait à charge de
l'étudiant à 50%
il restait à charge du crous aujourd'hui
quand vous acheter un repas ou dans un
restaurant universitaire le repas est un
euro momentanément plus que bien sûr
depuis le mois de janvier prise
république a étendu seront pas un euro
aux étudiants boursiers et à tous les
étudiants
mais sinon ça coûte 3 euros 30 par
contre il n'y a pas de restaurants
universitaires partout beaucoup de
villes moyennes qui n'ont pas de
restaurant universitaire donc les
étudiants ne peuvent pas avoir accès à
cette restauration à 1 euro ou à 3,030
donc l'idée de ce ticket restaurant
c'est de rétablir cette injustice cette
inégalité permettre donc à tous les
étudiants parce que ça s'applique à tous
les étudiants d'utiliser ce ticket
restaurants partout dans tous les
endroits où on prend le ticket resto si
à peu près calqué sur le même modèle que
le ticket resto entreprises vous l'avez
financer cette mesure elle coûterait
combien j'ai envie de vous dire que
c'est pas forcément un problème de
financement puisque si tous les
étudiants aujourd'hui de france se
rendait nu à manger à midi dans un
restaurant universitaire ils auraient
droit européen euros donc ce n'est pas
un problème de financement puisqu'ils
ont accès à cette offre
c'est simplement qu'ils ne peuvent pas
en profiter puisque a pas de restaurants
universitaires partout je rappelle
également que le président la république
a dit encore récemment il ya le fameux
quoi qu'il en coûte
nous sommes en train de parler de notre
jeunesse est ce que vous trouvez normal
de voir des gens c'est des jeunes fer la
plus devant des banques alimentaires de
faire la queue devant les restaurants du
coeur encore hier des reportages montré
des étudiants qui avait lui même pas de
quoi s'acheter un dentifrice acheter des
produits d'hygiène de première nécessité
donc là on est en face de vraiment d'une
crise terrible des étudiants aujourd'hui
sont dans une précarité la plus totale
beaucoup n'ont plus le petit travail
pour financière aux études donc je crois
que le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est
mathieu dans leur donner du pouvoir
d'achat et je compte sur le gouvernement
pour trouver les financements
nécessaires pour financer cette idée
tickets resto rester avec nos évidemment
on va continuer d'en discuter en plateau
et vous manifester si vous souhaitez
réagir eric heyer c'est une bonne idée
c'est ça va donner un coup de pouce aux
étudiants non mais c'est une fin c'est
une bonne idée encore une fois est ce qu
elles suffisantes je sais pas mais en
tout cas c'est une très bonne idée
effectivement aujourd'hui
alors il faudrait peut-être un peu la
cible et mais il vous avez à peu près
250 mille étudiants qui travaillent en
même temps que leurs études parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens et donc là c'est
une catastrophe pour cela ce peut être
une catastrophe pour les autres mais
pour ces 250 miss et ils vont y ait un
grand risque qu'ils arrêtent même leurs
études parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas le
financer et donc c'est une catastrophe
pour eux si une catastrophe pour
l'avenir de l'économie française oui
c'est quand on arrête les études on va
être moins productifs c'est pas une
bonne chose de voir des étudiants
arrêtés
- pour les bien sûr et donc du coup pour
la productivité de demain ce n'est pas
bon donc bien entendu qu'il faut aider
en priorité ses 250 milles qui bat déjà
on sait très bien que quand on travaille
en même temps que ses études on a une
probabilité de réussite qui est plus
faible
bon d'air et donc ces personnes là il
faut doublement lésés des donc ça passe
bien entendu par accéder à delà des
repas tous les jours et être bien
nourris mais aussi être bien logés et
donc effectivement on pourrait à côté
accompagné de cette idée de ticket
restaurant pas aussi les aider à se
loger correctement et de rester dans
dans dans leurs chambres universitaires
s'ils n'ont pas les moyens cam de
financer cela donc il faut aller bien au
delà alors peut-être que d'un point de
vue du coup il faut le cibler oui vous
avez quand même d'aider des étudiants
qui ne sont pas dans cette difficulté là
qui ont la chance d'avoir des parents
qui les loge qui les nourrissent
et c'est donc on pourrait cam un tout
petit peu les cibler parce que et mettre
réellement l'accent sur ceux qui ont des
grosses difficultés aujourd'hui et qui
vont décrocher et ça c'est une
catastrophe de la jeunesse pas vraiment
pour tous les étudiants
eric delannoy l'auront pas vraiment
position enfin les conditions
effectivement de mise en oeuvre de ce
sujet est important
regardez moi je voudrais enfin soulevé
deux points le premier je suis
parfaitement d'accord sur le fait que
faut pas oublier que le logement pour
les étudiants c'est trois fois le budget
alimentaire et que effectivement dans le
cadre de la crise actuelle c'est plutôt
le logement dont ils auraient besoin
qu'une nouvelle bonne idée qui est une
très bonne idée sur l'alimentation bon
ça c'est un premier point
moi ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est que
des bonnes idées on en a beaucoup mais
après c'est l'exécution l'exécution
pourquoi parce qu'on se rend compte que
dans cette crise ce qui a fait défaut
depuis un an c'est des problématiques
d'exécution exécution sur les masques
exécution sur la vaccination
là on est en train de mettre en place
une bonne idée qui va falloir voter qui
va faire budgété si en plus on met des
conditions de ciblage il va falloir le
mettre en oeuvre ces conditions de
ciblage elles vont être difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre parce que dans les
régions il n'y a pas toutes les mêmes
infrastructures pour que les étudiants
puissent y avoir accès à cette offre là
bref je suis curieux de savoir comment
on va faire en sorte que cette mesure
soit mise en
avant l'année prochaine alors que c'est
maintenant que ces décisions là ont
besoin de faire quelque chose et être
que pouvait nous répondre sur ce point
pierre antoine lévy quel est le chemin
parlementaire de ceux de cette
proposition de loi et est encore une
application concrète
alors tout d'abord jeu pour revenir sur
ce que vient de dire de nous inviter jeu
moi je suis pour que le ticket
restaurant soit voté pour tout le monde
ensuite avec un regard particulier pour
les étudiants les plus précaires on
parle de repas un euro on peut imaginer
que l'on laisse le le financement de
l'étudiant auteur d'un euro sur le
ticket restaurant ans pour les étudiants
les plus précaires vous avez raison de
dire que c'est le logement également une
problématique mais c'est aussi le fait
de faire à manger de se faire à manger
ne pas voir assez pour manger tous les
jours ce que je j'ai proposé dans la
proposition de loi c'est tout simplement
de décider de la beauté le plus vite
possible au sénat si elle est votée en
juin au sénégal peut arriver rapidement
l'assemblée nationale ensuite allez
voter dans une niche soit dans la niche
de la députée un anglais soit dans un
groupe qui peut éventuellement
l'accueillir pidc cas soit votée avant
la fin de l'année bien évidemment parce
que si elle maintenant que disent ils en
ont besoin c'est pas dans deux ans il
faut également garder cette bonne idée
d'avoir le repas un euro en attendant
pour tous je crois que ça c'est une
obligation
aujourd'hui qu'il faut avoir je rappelle
également que 80 % des cours sont à
distance yale et iliad est donc d
urgence de trouver des solutions pour
permettre à des étudiants le seul
d'acheter à manger
les étudiants qui sont distanciés n'ont
pas accès aux restaurants universitaires
donc il faut aller très vite pour
attendre un an pour que cette loi soit
votée enfin malheureusement on à
l'illustration de ce que j'évoque là
c'est qu'on va se retrouver avec une
mesure qui dans le meilleur des cas
rentrera en heure début d'année
prochaine milieu d'année prochaine et je
vous parle pas des inégalités qui va y
avoir entre les territoires ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas le faire et
qu'il faut le petit ne faut pas le faire
et c'est encore trop lents mais c'est
incroyablement lents et la leçon de
cette crise si on doit en tirer une
c'est quand est ce qu'on va des
bureaucratisé tout ça
quand est ce qu'on va mettre en place un
état qui soit capable d'être réactif
pour faire face à des crises parce
qu'une crise comme celle là
malheureusement je crains que dans les
dix prochaines années on en aura
d'autres et on ne peut pas continuer à
avoir de bonnes idées et d'être
incapable de les mettre en oeuvre
conditions et on s'arrêtera sur ce thème
merci infiniment pierre antoine lévy d'y
avoir participé
ponctuellement on va enchaîner avec le
troisième thème de ce match messieurs il
concerne hubert le géant américain de
réservation de voitures pour la première
fois de son histoire
il reconnaît à des chauffeurs
britannique à ses chauffeurs britannique
un statut de travailleur salarié
concrètement ça veut dire que depuis ce
matin soixante dix mille britannique
bénéficie d'un salaire minimum et de
congés payés
cela bouge d'ailleurs un peu partout en
europe en espagne un décret va
reconnaître le statut de salarié de
plein droit pour les coursiers des
plateformes de livraison de repas à 10 à
domicile donc des livres ou ibérique
il s'agit d'une loi pioneer pour
pionnier en europe je vais y arriver
pardon a déclaré la ministre du travail
espagnol et en france alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait eh bien on a le sénateur
socialiste olivier jacquin qui a fait
une proposition de loi
mais pour lui le gouvernement protège
les plateformes écouté mon groupe
politique au sénat a réussi par deux
fois à dire au gouvernement par le
conseil constitutionnel que ces lois
n'allait pas par deux fois le conseil
constitutionnel a dit mais non madame la
ministre anne 20 ans et là il continue
encore et encore à tenter de protéger la
forme plus que les travailleurs des
plateformes eric heyer est ce qu'on peut
considérer que le gouvernement français
a tendance à être trop conciliant avec
les plateformes au détriment des
travailleurs indépendants qui n'arrivent
pas à accéder à un statut mais c'est
avec le statut de ces indépendants ça va
être enfin en tout cas de ces
travailleurs indépendants ça va être
quelque chose que en fait il ya d'un
côté le salarié d'un côté les
indépendants qui existait depuis peu ils
sont un peu au milieu c'est à dire que
globalement ils sont indépendants
juridiquement mais on voit très bien qui
sont dépendants économiquement c'est
d'accéder plateforme qui décide quelque
part de leurs revenus et donc cette
dépendance économique fait que
effectivement il faudrait qu'on leur
trouve un statut qui les protège
puisqu'ils sont dépendants
économiquement mais il va il n'existe
pas depuis hier mais du temps quand même
lyon met du temps parce que globalement
si on crée il si on commence à créer un
troisième statut il ya quand même une
énorme crainte que beaucoup de salariés
passent dans ce statut là beaucoup
d'entreprises
semeta et donc ça serait une
précarisation des salariés aujourd'hui
donc voyez que c'est assez compliqué
donc ça doit être vraiment du sur mesure
et du cas par cas
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué donc
faut dresser d'envisager enfin il ya des
pistes mais d'envisager finalement ces
plateformes comme une boîte d'intérim
oui c'est il ya un intérimaire dans une
boîte et la société d'intérimaires il ya
le la personne qui travaille pour
l'intérim et puis il ya le client les
plateformes ça serait un peu comme une
boîte d'intérim et donc il va falloir
qu'on trouve ce statut et voyons mal an
on parle même de cdi intérimaires dont
vous voyez petit à petit on arrive à
mettre un statut sur ces plateformes il
va falloir aller la donc attention à ne
pas créer un statut dans cette zone
grise
attention parce que globalement ça on va
mettre beaucoup de personnes là dedans
et essayer de trouver à ce set go
comment on rémunère cette dépendance
économique comment protège de cette
dépendance économique
ou alors que ça vienne d'hubert mais
sous la pression de la justice comme ça
a été le cas en voilà le problème de la
pression de la justice c'est qu'elle
rend des jugements qui sont sûr j'ai
envie de dire l'ancien monde
on est en train d'essayer de re faire
rentrer au chausse pied une nouvelle
manière de travailler et on va voir que
c'est pour moment ça on n'y est pas sur
comment bien sûr que c'est eux les vieux
n'oublions pas qu'entre 2010 et 2020 on
est sur x 5 en terme de plateforme
donc c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose
qui est en train de se développer ça se
développe exponentiellement pourquoi
parce que beaucoup de jeunes qui ne se
retrouvent pas dans le salariat par
rapport à la protection à la dépendance
hiérarchie par rapport à beaucoup de
sujets qui ne plaisent pas beaucoup de
personnes ils veulent pouvoir maîtriser
leur destin monter leur entreprise et
faire en sorte de pouvoir faire leur job
maintenant effectivement l'innovation
est toujours en avant sur réglementation
et aujourd'hui on essaie de traiter ces
nouveaux travailleurs qui propose une
nouvelle forme de travail avec les
outils d'hier on va devenir des
travailleurs on va les salariés ce qui
se passe en angleterre est juste
hallucinant on va en faire des
travailleurs de place de plateformes ça
va devenir des salariés en cuisinant
mais c'est gênant par le fait qu'on ne
reconnaît pas à ce type de travail à
cette émergence d'un nouveau type de
travail sa spécificité qui à la fois une
spé cité autour du vin désir personnel
d'autonomie et qui peut être aussi à la
fois une
une flexibilisation plus importante par
rapport à des métiers classiques ça il
faut le reconnaître aujourd'hui l'autre
blocage réglementaire c'est que
forcément ils sont travailleurs
indépendants qui dépendent du coup du
code du commerce et le code du commerce
interdit d'avoir des conventions
collectives de travail heures tir est
qu'ils se mettraient ensemble parce que
il ya une notion cartel mais donc
d'entente illicite
bref encore une fois on est sur une
réglementation qui est en retard sur
cette règlement de sur eux sur les
nouvelles formes de travail ce qui me
semble important c'est justement de
profiter de cette zone grise pour
essayer d'inventer un nouveau système
qui protégerait pris ce qu'on peut faire
on peut on savait déjà été fait dans
d'autres systèmes
hubert parce que justement ils sont dans
cette relation avec les travailleurs ils
vont prendre une partie des marges
considérables qu'ils ont puisque
effectivement ils appauvrissent enfin le
transfert de valeur ils hallucinent
entre ces gens là qui sont totalement
appauvri et des plateformes qui qui qui
sortit sur le rendement croissant c'est
qu'une partie de leur marge il est même
dans des fonds que ce fonds soit là pour
protéger mettre au service d une
protection sociale des formations mais
aussi le travailleur pourrez y accéder
de manière libre sans avoir un lien de
subordination par rapport à la plate
forme
je pense que c'est vers ça qu'il
faudrait réussir à aller c'est compliqué
ça prendra du temps mais néanmoins on va
enfin reconnaître une nouvelle forme de
travail qui n'est pas le salariat et qui
n'est pas l'entrepreneuriat eric est une
façon de faire c'est au lieu de deux il
ya eu deux mois importants qui ont été
dites ou de mon point de vue il ya
subordination et autonomie ce que
veulent les les jeunes c'est pas être
indépendant c'est être autonome c'est
différent c'est à dire appartenir à une
structure ça les gêne pas en revanche il
faut être autonome par rapport à cette
structure est donc ce n'est pas un lien
de subordination qu'il faudrait mettre
en place mais un lien juste de contrôle
c'est à dire que je décide moi de ma
durée du travail
dada de mon lieu de travail d'un certain
nombre de choses et tout en ayant la
protection alors et ensuite mon
employeur s'il est d'accord avec cela
d'accord donc c'est calme et me
contrôler ok tu dis que tu travailles
ici ok tu dis tu travailles tendeur ok
je te contrôler mais du coup je te
protège aussi mes donc on change le lien
c'est plus la subordination c'est du
contrôle et donc si une autonomie
contrôler d'accord mais on met
mais du coup c'est pas de l'indépendance
non plus donc et hélas peut-être que
l'intégralité des salariés pourrait
vouloir aller vers cette autonomie
contrôler plutôt que vers cette
indépendance ou ce lien de subordination
et ça effectivement c'est assez
passionnant à y réfléchir et conduit à
une vaste chantier quatrième thème de ce
match messieurs l'éviction des manuels
faber on en a beaucoup parlé en début de
semaine désormais ex pdg de danone donc
il était dans le viseur de quelques
actionnaires qu'ils jugent irresponsable
de mauvaises performances du groupe en
perte de vitesse à cause de la crise
sanitaire
l'annoncé a fait l'effet d'un coup de
tonnerre d'autant plus que l'homme
prenait prônait ce qu'on appelle un
capitalisme social un capitalisme humain
laurent berger à d'ailleurs fait part de
ses craintes étaient hier sur notre
plateau sur public sénat écoutez nous on
était très attaché à la gouvernance à ne
pas dire qu'on est attaché à l'homme
même si moi j'ai beaucoup de risques
team pour premier faber la gouvernance
était quoi c'était simplement c'est être
considéré qu'une entreprise c'est pas
simplement un but un but de rentabilité
à tout crin sera aussi une
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale
si l'éviction de monsieur faber c'est la
contradiction de ce qui est
historiquement danone bouger beaucoup de
craintes il ya des raisons d'être
inquiet eric delannoy alors à titre
personnel je pense pas je pense qu'il ya
un énorme contresens qui est véhiculé
actuellement sur l'éviction des manuels
faber au contraire un ce que dit laurent
berger très intéressant
la loi aujourd'hui protège les
engagements que prendra note en terme
social et environnemental c'est avec la
loi pâques la société a mission il faut
rappeler que ce n'est pas une démarche
qui est très récente qui est venu comme
ça c'est depuis 2005 chez danone qu'ils
ont réfléchi à ce sujet et cette mise
dans les statuts qui va protéger les
engagements sociaux environnementaux a
été voté à 99 % par les actionnaires
donc c'était palier où les alphabets
remet les noms les actionnaires sont pas
des gens comme ça des méchants qui vont
tout à coup prendre des mesures contre
productive 20 jours voter les ongles
les engagements environnementaux et puis
un jour les derniers noms ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est justement ces
engagements là vont survivre au départ
d'emmanuel faber ce qui se passe avec
emmanuel faber aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
ya eu à mon avis deux erreurs
importantes une première qui est de mal
communiqué autour de sa restructuration
et qui a fait dire que la société a
mission n'était pas forcément le bon
système mais si une entreprise a mission
une société mission tenzing société
mission donc on le connaît bien le sujet
doit faire des bénéfices pour pouvoir
financer la transformation pour réussir
à aller vers sa mission et dans les
engagements des manuels faveur il n'est
pas de réduire le chômage en france
donc les 1400 personnes qui ont été on
va dire fait l'objet d'un plan de
restructuration
c'était pour aller dans le sens de
l'économie circulaire pour rapprocher
sont des décisions au niveau local donc
on si la communication avait été fait
pour mettre en perspective ces
restructurations par rapport aux
engagements des manuels faber déjà on
aurait eu moins de critiques
d'opposition entre capitalisme et
comportements d'entreprise premier sujet
deuxième sujet emmanuel faber alors là
pour le coup je ne connais pas
l'intimité de danone mais on parle d'une
d'un caractère un peu autocrate
management joueurs de délai de départ
effectivement un management très dur
donc une espèce de dissonance entre la
personne et potentiellement la mission
puisque dans les engagements il ya de
l'économie inclusive il y à
l'implication des collaborateurs et
cette dissonance là bas quelque part la
mission et la décision des actionnaires
protège l'entreprise compte cette
distance là quelque part c'est peut-être
au contraire parce que emmanuel faber
n'incarnez pas suffisamment 7 7 7 7
cette espèce de d'engagement qui sont
pris dans la durée qu'il a été évincé
et dernier point ça pose néanmoins la
question deux pour les actionnaires de
la réparation de la valeur on dit
souvent qu'il ya des fous des fonds
activistes qui veulent plus de
rentabilité mais eux mêmes les fonds
activistes sont pris dans des
engagements qui sont contradictoires
rémunérer leurs propres actionnaires le
salarié du de l'arkansas qui lui
rendement pour sa future retraite
d'accord et puis le fait de bien prendre
conscience que sans durabilité dans les
investissements
ils n'y arriveront pas et donc si
c'était quilibre là qui se joue avec
danone et c'est pour ça que je crois au
contraire que ce qui se passe chez
danone va servir l'entreprise a mission
parce que ça fait avancer tout le monde
en fait vous êtes d'accord eric heyer
parce que ça fait réagir beaucoup de
personnalités de gauche qui ont aimé la
figure des manuels faber oui parce qu'il
a tenu des très beaux discours et
effectivement il y avait le discours qui
était assez séduisant il y avait aussi
un certain nombre d'éléments enfin
danone était historiquement un peu dans
cette ligne là c'est pas uniquement
emmanuel faber donc on aimer cela on
aimait ce discours là bon ensuite il y
avait quand même des résultats qui
étaient pas si catastrophique alors
certes il faisait moins bien que
certains concurrents
d'accord mais il avait gamme des
résultats positifs en période en 2020 en
période de grande crise économique donc
on pouvait pas dire que c'était non plus
une catastrophe donc on se dit tiens
c'est ont très vite on peut dire bah
c'était pas suffisant parce que le
concurrent faisant mieux au lieu d'avoir
14 de marge il faudrait qu'on est 18
2011 et des moins bons parce qu'il
faisait du social ou pas voilà c'est ça
la question c'est est ce que dit il il
avait des moins bons résultats que
nestlé parce qu'il faisait du social ou
parce qu'il a fait des mauvais choix
stratégiques
il a pu faire il a quand même changé
souvent d'avis est-ce que c'était des
spécialisations par produit par pas à
pas par zone géographique est donc ça
moi je suis bien mal pour vous dire ce
qu'il a fait des mauvais choix si je
sais pas donc est-ce qu'ils ont des
moins bons résultats
pour quelles raisons ils ont fait les
moins bons résultats mais ça c'était aux
actionnaires at a plus ou moins à nous
le dire alors c'est sûr que quand c'est
des fonds activistes qui font des
pressions et on sait que ces fonds
arrivent finalement il ya un an deux ans
donc on a on a toujours cette crainte
que en fait ils soient là dans le court
terme il essaie d'avoir le maximum de
résultats puis partir mais c'est
peut-être qu'une crainte peut-être
qu'effectivement il s'inscrivait dans le
long terme c'est pour ça que ça c'est
assez compliqué et quand on a on est une
entreprise de mission il faudrait qu'ils
aient une sorte de grille de lecture
plus simple en disant voilà quels sont
nos objectifs
et est ce qu'on les a atteint 2 point de
vue là et puisqu'on les a pas on peut
toujours dire si on les a pas fait assez
et c'est donc
aujourd'hui ça veut pas dire grand chose
ces entreprises donc il faudrait mettre
un peu à un sort de tableau de bord
aussi pour pas uniquement pour les
résultats financiers mais pour ces
missions là elle pouvoir 6,6 la a été au
détriment de l'autre mais là vraiment
j'ai du mal à le dire effectivement il
ya on peut réagir d'un point de vue plus
idéologique autre chose oui mais c'est
le cas en fait le comité de mission est
là pour bien mettre en oeuvre auprès de
tout le monde que les objectifs qui sont
pris les engagements qui sont prises
seront atteints et ce comité de mission
chez danone n'a pas été remis en cause
donc moi je pense que cette crainte
parce qu'ils sont se tait la mission il
n'ya pas l'avoir léser les actionnaires
ont pris acte que demain ils auront des
engagements à tenir et ses mots de la
fin merci merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce match des idées fin de
cette émission se retrouvent demain à 18
heures et à 22h30 en attendant bonjour
chez vous dès 7h30 au rayonnement de
chimie recevra l'ancien premier ministre
jean pierre raffarin
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur public sénat
pour revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
dans la crise sanitaire les élus locaux
eux aussi sont en première ligne
confinement déconfinement couvre-feu pas
simple d'appliquer localement les
consignes venues d'en haut
la relation entre les maires et les
services de l'état c'est souvent tendues
quel est le meilleur et flon pour
traiter des questions de santé
ce sera notre débat de la semaine autour
de notre film mon maire recombiner cette
semaine dans un monde en doc un montant
gorge
samedi à 21h sur public sénat